Speaker 1: . Fox News reporter Peter Doocy
is back in the White House press briefing
room and is simply determined to end up humiliating
himself at absolutely every opportunity.
Now, I want to be really clear here, because
every time we talk about stuff like this,
I get emails.
David, how are you now?
Just accepting everything that the White House
press.
No, no, no, no, no.
Every White House press secretary distorts
answers selectively, flame frames, everything
that an administration does in the best possible
light.
This is their job.
That being said, there is a real difference.
When Jen Psaki replaced Kayleigh McEnany,
when Joe Biden became president and Donald
Trump left, there was a significant change,
which was that, at least in principle, the
briefings became about substance and most
reporters were able to start asking mostly
substantive questions.
You still get PR answers.
That's the role of a press secretary.
I'm not denying that.
Fox News's Peter Doocy is a notable exception
to most reporters are trying to ask substantive
questions.
He's been focused from day one on asking bizarre,
leading, loaded, inaccurate and even childish
questions, constantly trying to trap Jen Psaki
and even Joe Biden, sometimes in a gotcha
type situations.
And Peter Doocy did the exact same thing on
Friday.
That's the most recent press briefing as as
of right now, I think there is one scheduled
for a little bit later today.
And Jen Psaki was having absolutely none of
it.
Peter Doocy here is trying to jump all over
a report that the U.S. surgeon general's office
put out a which is that there is a small number
of primary disseminators of covid and vaccine
disinformation on social media, 12 people.
In fact, we've known for some time that a
huge portion of the Antibalas disinformation
originates from a small number of accounts.
They've been tracking vaccine disinformation
at the surgeon general's level.
And Peter Doocy frames it as a personal targeted
spying campaign.
And here is how that exchange went.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: OK, so these 12 people who you
have on a list of 12 individuals,
Speaker 1: do they even have this idea of
a list as nefarious?
How else do you categorize things instead
of a list you have?
What by definition, if you're aware of 12
people, it's colloquially a list, but he's
even trying to weaponize list.
So then later, right wingers can say this
is a McCarthyite list of some kind.
Speaker 3: OK, did somebody at the surgeon
general's office is going through their profile?
Speaker 4: I'm happy to get you the citation
of where that comes from.
There's no secret list.
I will tell you that these are people who
are sharing information on public platforms,
on Facebook.
Information that is traveling is inaccurate.
Our biggest concern here, and I frankly think
it should be your biggest concern is the number
of people who are dying around the country,
because that's
Speaker 1: not his biggest concern.
You know, that's a it's just not
Speaker 4: getting misinformation that is
leading them to not take a vaccine.
Young people, old people, kids, children.
This is all being a lot of them are being
impacted by misinformation and concern,
Speaker 3: though I think for a lot of people
on Facebook is that now this is Big Brother
watching you.
Speaker 4: They're more concerned about that
than people dying.
Speaker 1: The most people on Facebook are
saying, why is the anti vaccine stuff even
being allowed on Facebook?
Speaker 4: Because of a pandemic where misinformation
is traveling on social media platforms.
That feels unlikely to me if you have the
data to back that up.
I'm happy to discuss that.
Speaker 1: So this is quite well handled,
it's not just some Jen Psaki victory party.
Jen Psaki is a mouthpiece for the administration.
This is her job.
It's no special virtue, but she's doing a
good job of pointing out hold on, the vaccine.
Disinformation leads to death.
That should be the primary concern.
Ninety nine plus percent of hospitalizations
are unvaccinated.
Ninety nine point two percent of the deaths
last month were unvaccinated and incomes.
Steve Doocy again.
And this is how you craft narrative to later
repeat on Fox News announcement from yesterday.
Speaker 3: For how long has the administration
been spying on people's profiles looking for
vaccine and misinformation?
Speaker 4: Well, that was quite a loaded and
accurate question, which I would refute.
How?
Well, Peter, first of all, as you know, we're
we're in our regular touch with with a range
of media outlets as well as let me finish
as we are,
Speaker 1: as we just like an insufferable
little kid,
Speaker 4: are in regular touch with social
media platforms.
This is publicly open information, people
sharing information online, just as you are
all reporting information on your news stations.
Speaker 1: OK, announcement from yesterday.
So, by the way, just to be thorough, very
well sourced, this Jen Psaki is communicating
about research that found 12 people are behind
a huge amount of the vaccine hoax information,
disinformation on social media.
OK, there's a very good NPR article about
it from a couple of months ago.
It's been continued to be looked at.
Researchers found 12 people are responsible
for the bulk of the misleading claims and
outright lies about covid vaccines that proliferate
on Facebook, Instagram and Twitter.
The disinformation doesn't produce 65 percent
of the shares of anti vaccine misinformation
on social media platforms.
So there's no doubt about the data.
But the concern with imaginary spying when
what we're talking about is the enforcement
of terms of service and a study of where this
stuff is coming from, the priorities are completely
backwards.
And Steve Steve, Peter Doocy, Steve Doocy,
Sun continuing to just make a fool out of
himself.
But the problem is a lot of the Trump supporters
don't see it this way.
You might say a normal person would see this
and they would say, hold on a second.
Ninety nine percent of the that hospitalized
are unvaccinated, 99 percent of the deaths
are unvaccinated.
Now, if you perpetuate anti VAX disinformation,
which prevents people from getting vaccinated,
you're essentially leading to people's deaths.
That's incredibly serious and absolutely immoral.
The focus should be on stopping that.
But no, it's about the surgeon general's office,
quote, spying.
And unfortunately, it works.
It works on the Fox News audience.
It works on the legacy Rush Limbaugh audience
that that is now kind of fragmented in listening
to different shows.
So completely missing the plot.
And Peter Doocy continuing to make a fool
out of himself on a regular basis.